aren taking it they're not winning
because the goalie stands on his
head every night Demco has been very good
so is Casey to Smith but a very thorough
team play attitude here for the Canucks as
Patterson moves in here's kzo shooting his
stors 96 scores 94 seconds into
the game and the conu lead one
nothing Pon receives a wonderful stretch
pass and tries to move it to the middle
some loose change there and kenko
he is on it early and so are the
Canucks he wanted that pass all the way
tapping the ice beating the goalie now
Miller back to Pon who was behind the play
bit because the Canucks had the drop pass
option but now they're all in the offensive
zone Hughes has the Pucket the rightwing
hashmark back to Pon Miller takes a look
puts it in front TI in K meno's got another
one it's a jolly return to the lineup
for Andre kzco and the can lead two
nothing what a redemption in this game so
far the tip in the slot area Hughes back
to the point Miller is going to throw right to
the plade Janko just turns the wrists a little
bit to change the angle over that glove hand
both goals have gotten there against Blackwood
and a costly offensive zone penalty by the
Sharks checked as he tried to slide one in
front kzco digging for the pck he has one
career hatrick as Andre kzco came against
the Anaheim Ducks last year here's duclair
into the van on the right wing he shoots he
scores off the rush Anthony declair able to
beat Thatcher Demco and get the Sharks on the
board got a pass there from granin and granin was
able to move the stick out of the way of zador
off at that time and over the blocker might
have hit granin in the skate off his stick
went off his stick and up over Demo's shoulder
so it was a low shot yeah you see him putting
his hand in the air there they both celebrate I
don't think Zid was expecting that one at least
not such a hard pass from Close Quarters but Pon
gives the puck away to Eckland and here's a long
shot from the line Dem this sa big rebound hurdle
scores to Mas hurdle able to sneak it through the
pads on the back end and his eighth goal of the
month of December ties it up at two wasn't able
to make a crisp breakout pass shot towards the net
battle in and PE puts it underneath Meyers and the
goenda fairy tale kusano story he is taking
oh he might get better now he's in in and
he couldn't get a good shot of it now it's
brought in front by zerland checked by KZ
Ferraro plays the puck back in deep thrown in
front and a glorious save by Demco off Anthony
duclair 10 seconds to go in the power play for
San Jose Zena that pass comes outside the line and
Ferrero dumps it across Center picked off by bler
he's in with Oman Teddy bler centers Oman scores
good Puck work this is by bler he's going to
freeze with this fake shot and oh man a pass
to om man and it's in what a fake by Teddy
bler throws the goenda went down and it's
a backand right to Oman who's not going
to miss from there that is his second of
the Season Oman and the Canucks not only
kill the penalty but come ahead pardon me
they're not back the full stength there's few
seconds left in the power play Cole sent that
one across Garland down to M now Garland again
penalty's over Cole with a shot ticked in Sam
laery already to go off the shark
well the eles love that one back
to the point slapper laer he's trying to get
a stick on it and Bailey was doing the same
thing right there it changes Direction it
change direction again when it got towards
lty it looked like and William E tries
to carry out knocked off his stick by
Kusa but the Sharks able to move the puck
ahead to granet M granet to Mario Ferraro
turns and centers zum scor there were
two sharks in front the furo pass went
beyond the first Target but zelin there
to one time at home and make it four to
three we're able to get back to the front of
the net FR running out a room just spins to
the front it looks like it's going to go all the
way to Eckland and instead it's on the stick of
zland he's just waiting to see if this will
come to him it does as pass the blocker then
Joshua tried to make a play in his own
Zone and this might cost the canx here's
hurdle centers the puck and off the crossbar
goes zerin as eckan moves back in broken up
hurdle keeps the puck alive Oman after now
shooter ties up his man but here's a shot
by eckan as he spun and fired and Demco made
the save here comes heric back onto the ice
sharks are 0 for three on the power play they
tested Eno three times on that one still 4-3
Vancouver here come the Canucks four of them to
Center Conor Garland looks across here's Joshua
scores those two have something KN ninth of
the year for Joshua Garland's been on on most
of them and the Canucks are back up by a couple
P get spit out of the neutral zone Luger gives
it to Garland and he's just going to hold it wait
and pass across this is just like the other night
in Dallas not looking at the guy you're going
to give it to and he's going to get it Joshua
beats the go who can't get across in time let's
go of his stick but that's not going to help 53
Vancouver here's a shot by Ruda tle the
save oh he stopped the rebound as well
might have been a scorpion now a
Glo save off the long shot from
auk Sharks win the draw Ruda puts one in
front Tempco another save they score on
the rebound sharks had the better plan on
that one Jacob McDonald able to roof the
loose Puck and it's a onego game again
with 644 to go just thrown towards the
front of the net down the right wing off
bodies in front and McDonald's there m
Demo's going across he does make that initial
stop with the right pad Miller line comes out
excepted got Pew Suter on it again we've
seen that a couple times this game TI Pew
Suter Rick toet Palms in the air a little bit
of the [__] I don't know if that's what he
was reacting to this clever move of coaching well
face off win Miller is trying to battle his way
to the front of the net and suda reaches out and
deflex this down so after the Canucks give up a
goal by missing their men at the fr front of the
net after a lost Face Off In Their Own Zone they
come back the conck DU to the same thing well it's
going to be a Holiday to Remember for Canucks fans
who would have thought it at the start of the year
as Quinn Hughes takes a look at the empty net he
scores Quinn Hughes with a multi-point
game 68th of his career he's already
tied the club record set by Alex Edler this
is a Nifty play he's going to elevate it up
and have it drop right into the net
Hughes had an assist on the Su goal
scores his own empty As Time runs out here the
Vancouver Canucks will head into the Christmas
break with a two-point lead in the overall
NHL standings as they beat the Sharks 74